did you know that one of the most
dangerous stunt driving scenes in all of
the Fast and the Furious movies was
filmed on a road that was deemed too
dangerous for the public to drive on and
that Paul Walker accidentally crashed
the car in his first time trying stunt
driving but the director liked the way
it looked so they kept it in the movie
in the Fast and Furious series we've
seen some of the craziest stunts of all
time cars have been driven off cliffs
they've been launched into the air
they've been crushed by tanks and
dropped from parking structures let's
take a look at some of the shocking
details about the Fast and Furious
stunts when a stunt driver in a movie
calls a particular stunt his favorite
you know it has to be good Robert Nagel
started on the series in Fast Five so
when it came time to film Fast and
Furious 6 he was pretty accustomed to
what was expected of all the stun actors
but even for Nagel the opening scene of
ff6 you guys cool if I call it that okay
great was way intense in the scene
Dominic Toretto AKA Vin Diesel and Brian
O'Connor AKA Paul Walker race down an
incredibly windy road in Spain they're
trying to make it to Mia Jordana
Brewster before she gives birth but this
was no ordinary race to a birth the two
of them curve around at insane speeds
with only giant rock faces on one side
and you know a plunge to their death on
the other filmed in Tenerife one of the
Canary Islands the shots are Beyond
gorgeous and almost beyond safe
according to Nagel he drove the camera
car which followed the two main cars at
PACE and driving the two cars were two
absolute Pros rally car expert Mark
Higgins and Ben Collins a former Top
Gear driver and Nagel admitted it wasn't
even the driving that caused him the
most stress it was the Spanish Road
itself he said the road had literally
been recently deemed too dangerous to
drive on and was officially closed to
the public so yeah not exactly the type
of terrain to make you feel safe driving
it fast and furious speeds but that was
just the half of it Nagel said the road
was littered with giant potholes and not
because the the local government was
slacking on their repair Crews the
potholes were because of the constantly
Falling Rocks that had been pummeling
the road so you know not great
conditions for safe stunt driving but
they managed to totally pull it off and
the scene looks incredible Jack Gill
decided to make the incredible happen
when he was stunt coordinator on Fast 8.
according to Gill when he got the script
it called for a simple drag race but he
knew better than that there was no way
he was going to let them basically show
the type of scene audiences had gotten
in almost all the movies so far he knew
he had to take it up a notch let's make
it big long lots of Corners lots of
speed Gil's goal was to show Havana Cuba
in a flattering way all the while
coordinating a hundred mile per hour
chases in 10 square blocks of tight city
streets and if that wasn't tricky enough
they also decided to have Vin Diesel's
car get set on fire you know just to
make things more difficult for him but
they had to figure out how to get the
right amount of fire enough for it to
look realistic and challenging but not
so so much that The Stunt Driver
couldn't see so they installed propane
pipes to pump in the fire and put
special gel on the stunt drivers to deal
with the Flames that kept wrapping
around into the car at one point the
heat was so intense for The Stunt Driver
they had to think fast the spin around
180 was because it got so hot on The
Stunt Driver we said why don't you drive
in reverse and it really goes just as
fast in Reverse as it does forward it's
like they always say if you can't stand
the heat drive backwards backwards isn't
the only strange direction that the Fast
and Furious stunts went in one of the
most famous stunts happened in the first
movie when Vin Diesel's charger flips
over a big rig to pull it off they used
a pipe ramp so his charger would fully
flip over the truck they were pretty
confident they'd be able to accomplish
that part the more challenging part The
Landing they really didn't know how the
car would react to that intense of a
flip and Landing they equipped it with
every safety component they could think
of like a thick roll bar and suspended
racing seat yet they didn't quite know
the path the car would take they weren't
sure how the flip would go and what part
of the car could make first contact with
the ground so when the car flipped
everyone held their breath and hoped for
the best fortunately it not only looked
great but the Stunt Driver landed safely
and the safety elements were hidden from
the camera and yet having stunt actors
Come Away unscathed for an entire movie
is still a staggering feat and spoiler
it didn't happen in all the Fast and
Furious movies in the first movie they
might have pulled off that charger flip
successfully but they also had a broken
leg of a stunt actor courtesy of a
pretty nasty motorcycle flip it's during
the chase scene when Brian is being
chased on motorcycles by Johnny Tran and
his cousin at one point one of the stunt
drivers flipped his bike onto like a
muddy section and the Motorcycle flipped
onto him it looked pretty incredible but
unfortunately it left him with a broken
leg and it wasn't really anything that
he or the stunt team did wrong sometimes
when it comes to pulling off amazing
stunts things can just go wrong
things also went wrong for a stunt Paul
Walker did in the second movie but in a
good way let me explain after the first
movie where all the stunts were handled
by stunt drivers Paul wanted to get in
on the action he was starting to really
get into cars and was intrigued by the
stunt driving so he convinced the
director John Singleton to let him do a
small stunt with an emergency brake stop
at the end of the first race sequence it
was a super simple stunt for any stunt
Pro but for Walker who was still new at
stunt driving it was a thrill that shot
went perfectly so Singleton decided to
let him try out some driving and a
police chase scene things did not go as
planned Walker ended up accidentally
flying over a curb and destroying a
parking meter not great right well it
turns out Singleton immediately watched
the footage and absolutely loved it they
kept it in the movie as if it had been
written into the script so a happy stunt
accident of course most of the time
stunt coordinators and drivers do
everything they can to make sure there
aren't any accidents one of the most
famous stunts involved two cars slamming
into each other they tried to plan
everything to Perfection but that's a
nearly impossible task when it comes to
two objects smashing into each other at
crazy speeds one of the cars the
Corvette flipped over which is not
something they realized would happen and
there was a distinct possibility things
could have gone seriously wrong for The
Stunt Driver fortunately the stunt
coordinator Terry Leonard aired on the
side of precaution before the shot he
made sure the Stunt Driver had a pull
strap in the stunt car it's a strap
that's just below the dash so if things
start to go Haywire the driver can yank
himself underneath the dash to be more
protected when the car starts to flip
and apparently this was what saved the
driver's life so next time you watch
this scene remember it not only looks
cool but a Stunt Driver risked his life
to give it to us and while the actors in
these movies aren't risking their lives
they can still have favorite stunts and
favorite scenes from the movies Jordana
Brewster for example got a total thrill
with one stunt in Fast Five even though
it caught her by surprise turned out I
had to jump off a building
she had never done any harness work
before and was TBH pretty scared on the
day but ultimately it was a good
experience for her that stunt was
special to me because Paul was so
patient for vin it's the tank sequence
in Fast and Furious 6. I mean the idea
that there's a lot of Ingenuity there
you see why guys are so proficient
they're able to rob you in motion for
Tyrese Gibson it's definitely the jump
off the bridge in Furious 7. all-time
favorite action scene had to be when van
and Paul drove off the cliff for
ludicrous it's when Tyrese's character
jumps onto a moving par favorite studies
when he jumps on the car at the end man
Gal Gadot said it's Gina and Michelle's
fight scene in fast six and Paul Walker
talked about how it was the fights he
liked the most okay I'm gonna go need to
watch some videos of like a calm stream
or a bunny rabbit something to get my
heart rate back down to normal because
simply talking about these insane stunts
is enough to get it well racing have any
thoughts on the wild stunts and the Fast
and Furious movies let us know in the
comment section below